Amal Clooney looks a fashionable as ever  while heading to work in NYC while  mary-kate and Ashley Olsen settle a  legal battle  [Music]  according to court documents obtained by  ec mary-kate and Ashley's company dual  star entertainment group will be paying  up to a hundred and forty thousand  dollars to a group of former interns who  alleged in a 2015 class-action lawsuit  they were either unpaid or paid less  than minimum wage after working extended  hours you guy again another fashionista  who is well versed in legal woes Amal  Clooney I think she likes working the  pregnant human rights lawyer stunned  while out in New York City Thursday  giving us major Jackie O vibes in this  vintage-inspired yellow and black cap  sleeve dress and matching coat George  Clooney's wife accessorized her ensemble  with black pumps a matching handbag and  Sonny's and her adorable growing belly  while heading into the UN to talk  international affairs  you